bienvenue dans à free connect l'afrique
doit-elle payer la facture conséquente
au changement climatique peut-elle
résister au poids écrasant des économies
mondiales qui imposent leurs lois ou
prennent des engagements difficile à
tenir peut-elle faire entendre sa voix
la coop 26 à glasgow on en parle tout de
suite avec notre invité le président du
groupe africain de négociateurs sur le
changement climatique tanguy gaou ma
bonjour tanguay gao ma merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans un tri
connecte sur arte france
bonjour et merci beaucoup d'avoir invité
l'afrique à pouvoir s'exprimer sur cette
importante question d'abord comment vous
réagissez un rapport dévoilé le 21
octobre par greenpeace et la bbc
révélant que des états ont tenté de
faire pression sur le rapport du giec le
groupe d'experts intergouvernemental sur
le climat sont pointés notamment
l'arabie saoudite qui craint l'abandon
des énergies fossiles ou encore
l'australie la fermeture de centrales à
charbon alors il faut dire ça fait
partie du jeu normal des nations dans
l'exercice que nous mais nombre des
changements climatiques les changements
climatiques sont très lourds et le
peuvent être parachuté c'est une
question quasiment de vie ou de mort
pour des continents comme l'afrique mais
c'est une question de développement
économique pour des pays occidentalisés
au des pays qui dépendent des ressources
fossiles donc évidemment on doit faire
attention aux mesures qui sont prises
mais en aucun cas on ne doit changer la
vérité parce que nous n'avons maintenant
que dix ans au prendre des accents
nécessaire et s'il ne prenait pas
maintenant il sera impossible pour nous
de faire face à ce qui va arriver demain
donc l'afrique ne cautionne pas
n'approuve pas toute manipulation qui
pèse fait envers ces données aujourd'hui
le dernier rapport à épices ici a prouvé
clairement que ce sont des humains qui
sont responsables des changements
climatiques et que nous avons dix ans
pour remédier définitivement à ce qui
s'est passé donc nous devons être
responsable c'est notre parano l'afrique
nous acceptons par solidarité
de partager les efforts que font les
autres pays les pays responsables mais
nous ne sommes pas responsables et nous
ne pouvons encourager des comportements
irresponsables et l'idée c'est de revoir
un vous l'avez dit l'accord de paris sur
le climat son article 6 précisément qui
régule les émissions de crédits carbone
c'est à dire le droit pour les états à
polluer en échange du financement des
énergies vertes en afrique que
demandez-vous que proposez vous
concrètement
alors pour l'afrique nous sommes à un
niveau différent de développement
lorsque par exemple en afrique on nous
parle de deux d'énergie propre pour les
véhicules en afrique il faut savoir que
1/3 du continent n'est pas connectée à
l'électricité la moitié de la population
n'a pas accès des véhicules
donc pour nous en afrique lorsqu on nous
parle de marché carbone pour nous c'est
pour sortir de la pauvreté c'est pour
accéder par exemple par une
autosuffisance alimentaire dans les pays
où c'est nécessaire c'est pour faire
face comme j'ai tout à l'heure à la
résilience aux conséquences du
changement climatique dont les enjeux
sont totalement différents nous devons
en effet accroître notre offre
énergétique et pour cela nous avons
besoin dans les pays
qui sont les plus ensoleillés de pouvoir
accéder au solaire donc nous avons
besoin de manière concrète d'avoir des
apu en termes de transfert des
technologies pour pouvoir accéder à des
panneaux solaires à moindre coût dans
les pays par exemple du bassin du congo
où il y a des potentiel hydroélectrique
extrêmement importantes qui peuvent
connecter quasiment toute l'afrique
centrale et l'afrique
du sud
a déjà des ressources renouvelables
libre existe et nous demandons donc que
des investissements colossaux soit fait
dans ce sens dans ce sens a donc pour
l'afrique la demande est clair nous
sommes
nous sommes vulnérables au changement
climatique donc nous avons besoin
d'appui pour protéger toutes les grandes
villes toutes les grandes cités qui sont
bordés côte donc libreville maputo dar
es salaam cape town
les gosses abidjan énormément de villes
africaines sont sur la côte donc on a
besoin d'appui très clair là dessus et
nous avons besoin de pouvoir confier
notre développement donc nourrir nos
populations et sortir de la pauvreté
principalement alors c'est vrai que
l'afrique c'est le continent qui
polluent le moins avec 4 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre ne souhaite pas
en tout cas payer la facture et le g20 a
lancé en 2011 un fonds vert destiné à
développer les énergies propres
problèmes sur les 100 milliards promis
par le g20 seuls 79 milliards ont été
payés en 2019 donc l'objectif il est
loin d'être atteint et selon l' ocde
l'afrique a reçu seulement 26 % des
fonds les pays asiatiques 43% comment
vous l'expliquez est ce que cela
signifie que finalement les pays
africains n'ont pas suffisamment de
projets a proposé dans ce domaine des
énergies renouvelables
le problème sur les énergies
renouvelables vous le trouvez sur tous
les autres composantes du financement
climatique l'afrique est un continent
qui a déconseillé à des circonstances
spéciales et que nous cherchons que nous
cherchons justement à faire approuver au
sein de la convention l'afrique ne peut
pas être traité comme l'amérique latine
ou comme l'asie quand des capacités de
développement totalement différente des
continents du continent africain par
exemple sur les sur les 54 pays
africains 33 sont des licences ont
partie des pays les moins développés
dans les pma nous avons 33 pays 33 des
pays les plus pauvres d'afrique ce en
afrique donc l'afrique a du mal à
accéder aux financements aujourd'hui ce
que nous demandons c'est justement que
l'afrique soit traité comme
comme les îles qui sont fragiles comme
les pays les moins avancés l'afrique est
un continent qu'il ya aussi des
circonstances spéciales qu'il faut
prendre en compte ce que vous dites sur
le financement et sur le financement des
énergies renouvelables est vrai pour
tous par exemple au sein du fonds vert
on a une facilité rennes plus donc pour
l'appui des forêts pts 2 500 millions de
dollars aucun pays africain n'a pu
accéder à ces 500 millions de dollars
qui sont majoritairement aujourd'hui qui
ont bénéficié majoritairement aux pays
d'amérique latine est ce que vous
dénoncez une sorte de discrimination
climatique voir un apartheid climatique
parce que aussi des problèmes on l'a vu
pour les délégations africaines qui sont
invités à participer à cette coop 26
problème des restrictions sanitaires des
obstacles l'administratif mais aussi des
problèmes de logement au regard du prix
du coût élevé des hébergements nous ne
voulons accuser personne mais si nous
laissons les choses se faire et si la
voix de l'afrique n'est pas entendue et
que ne sont pas prises en compte des
circonstances spéciales de l'afrique
dans le cadre des négociations climat il
est clair que l'afrique va être
discriminé l'afrique et ce processus ne
sera plus légitime parce que légitime
veut dire que tous les pays que tous les
continents s'exprime avec la même force
et si l'afrique ne peut pas s'exprimer
ne peut pas bénéficier des opportunités
les changements que changement
climatique offre pour se développer
l'afrique sera hors du système et alors
que nous représentons aujourd'hui 25%
quasiment du processus de négociation
avec 50 pays sur 196 pays donc il est
inadmissible aujourd'hui que la voix de
l'afrique ne puisse pas être écoutés
dans le cadre des commençants cas des
nations-unies sur les changements
climatiques tandis qu'à douma selon le
dernier rapport de l'onu sur le climat
il fait de plus en plus chaud en afrique
les températures et augmente à un rythme
plus élevé qu'ailleurs conséquence le
continent s'expose à des vagues de
chaleur plus extrêmes de graves
inondations côtières des précipitations
intenses sur le continent une situation
déjà bien avancé comme nous l'expliquent
grâce d'aia
bassin du congo des forêts luxuriantes à
l'importance cruciale pour la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique
la région abrite le deuxième massif
forestier tropical du monde après le
bassins d'amazonie ces forêts produisent
le dioxygène de l'air et fixe le co2
atmosphérique grâce à la photosynthèse
ce n'est pas pour rien qu elles sont
appelées poumon vert de la planète en
2010 est le fond bleu pour le bassin du
congo a été créé objectif préserver ses
forêts tout en garantissant un
développement économique aux populations
de la région mais aussi lutter contre
les effets néfastes du réchauffement
climatique
à saint-louis lille sénégalaise de plus
de deux cent trente sept mille habitants
la montée de l'océan atlantique a déjà
fait son oeuvre délogeant près de 3000
personnes depuis 2010 est alors pour
parer au pire le gouvernement s'est
lancé dans un projet un peu trop
faramineux pour les habitants une digue
de 3,6 km de long parce que le nu
ce projet de construction d'une digue
est venu trop tard roman de rire
ça ne sert à rien de jouer les médecins
après la mort vainio
ils ont attendu que des milliers de
francs cfa soient engloutis par la mer
pour venir aujourd'hui mettre ces
pierres
érosion côtière vent violent inondations
marine de par sa géographie et sa
construction anarchique saint louis est
considérée comme l'une des villes
africaines les plus exposés à la montée
les océans en afrique de l'ouest
d'érosion fait reculer le trait de côte
de 1,8 mètre par an en moyenne
village de kunda détail kenya autres
zones autre problème climatique
ici c'est la sécheresse qui contraint
toute une population les massaï à
repenser totalement son mode de vie
tronqué le traditionnel bâton de berger
contre des bêches ou des pioches le
gouvernement de toute une vie
en un an je pouvais faire un tour
complet
je passais par mme à kindu par veille
n'a manga en tanzanie
au red dingues et tout autour et je
revenais chez moi
qu'à ce moment là il aurait à nouveau
plu ici et le cercle recommencerai pas
l'animal n'a je ne pense pas que nos
enfants connaîtront cette tradition
nomade rien
elle est terminée cammas a
abandonné le nomadisme au profit de
l'agriculture par dépit et être forcé de
s'adapter au changement climatique
serait ce la fin d'une culture d'un
monde près de six ans après l'accord de
paris sur le climat
dégâts dus au réchauffement climatique
ne cessent de se multiplier
le continent africain qu'il ne contribue
qu'à hauteur de 4% des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre mondiales en est
pourtant la victime majeure mais
l'afrique ne peut se mobiliser seul
alors pour glasgow l'objectif majeur est
que les pays développés continuent à
lever des fonds de financement
prochaines dates à l'agenda des
négociations climatiques novembre 2022
pour la coop 27 et cette fois sur le sol
africain en egypte
alors tanguay yahoo mais on vient de le
voir le bassin du congo c'est un enjeu
important qui peut permettre on l'a vu
dans ce sujet de lutter contre les
effets du changement climatique sur le
continent africain le gabon qui fait
partie de ce bassin du congo a lancé un
programme gabon émergent pour justement
optimiser l'exploitation des forêts cet
enjeu il est important dites nous
pourquoi aujourd'hui les forêts du
bassin du congo représentent le
principal bassin forestier au monde donc
nous sommes passés non pas en termes de
superficie mais en terme de
séquestration de carbone nous sommes
devenus le premier bassin séquestrer le
carbone au monde devant l'amazonie
aujourd'hui et devant le bassin d'asie
de l'est ont aujourd'hui le seul bassin
tropicale qui fournit des services réels
c'est aujourd'hui les frais des bassins
du komodo lorsque le président ali bongo
donc à lancer le pô le programme gabon
émergent il s'agissait pour lui de
pouvoir avoir un développement
compatible avec la préservation la
nature c'est pour ça que nous avons
protégé aujourd'hui quasiment 20% du
territoire et que nous venons de prendre
une loi sur les changements climatiques
qui définit désormais un plafond maximal
de dix mille hectares par an donc
désormais le gabon par exemple ne pourra
pas de déforester plus de dix mille
hectares par an jusqu'à jusqu'à ce qu'il
soit émergents et c'est un effort
extraordinaire que le verbe ont appris
pour pouvoir protéger ce patrimoine
immense pour l'humanité donc il ya un
mois on va marquer une courte pause et
on se retrouve tout de suite après
rester avec nous sur rt france dans la
grille connect
retour dans afrique connect nous sommes
avec tandis qu'à douma le président du
groupe africain des négociateurs sur le
changement climatique pour la coop 26
alors vous savez tanguy ko mac beaucoup
estiment que cette coop 26 ne va rien
changer que rien ne change d'ailleurs
depuis la coop 21 il accorde paris de
2015 écoutez à ce propos agustin chill
et président de l'alliance panafricaine
justice climatique au cameroun
ça n'a pas changé quelque chose et je
vous remercie de m'avoir posé deux
conditions
que à leur arrivée à paris en 2015
l'afrique en général avait des
projets des initiatives c'est qu'un pays
européen ne devrait pas ce que le nombre
connaissait très bien ce que je suis en
2010 ont supporté le livre politique
africaine pour arracher cette initiative
qui est un mythe initiative populaire à
l'afrique discuter sur le terrain avec
le peuple africain mais à la fin on en
sommes nous où en sommes nous avec cette
initiative c'est pourtant les
déclarations et qu'on a en main souvent
à la fin rien altéré chez nous sous le
financement climatique
est ce que le cameroun a eu beaucoup
d'argent 0 on n'a pas encore eu ça ne
veut pas dire que nous n'avons pas de
projet en âne pour les projets en asie
mais là les conditions et tout ça sonne
souvent difficile mais je repose la
question de savoir qui a créé ce
problème c'est les pays développés qui
ont créé ce problème on sait est ce que
les pays en voie de développement qui
souffrent de ce problème
doit faire la mendicité ou avant cet
argent sa ville revient à nous comme toi
parce que ce n'est pas nous qui avons
causé un problème
tanguy yaouba alors c'est vrai la
problématique de ces grandes messes
est-ce que c'est utile ou pas au final
ces grandes messes comme voulu comme
vous les appelez sont extrêmement utiles
parce que c'est ça le processus
multilatéral et les changements
climatiques ne peuvent pas être réglés
dans le cadre des relations bilatérales
donc nous sommes obligés de nous
rencontrer de discuter ensemble
depuis paris paris a été le premier
accord sur les changements climatiques
nous avons pu faire aboutir depuis que
la convention est né depuis paris
glasgow va être la conférence a plus
importante parce que nous avons enfin
fini de déterminer de design et les
modalités d'entrée en vigueur de cet
accord là donc tout ce qui est dans la
cour de paris maintenant fait l'objet de
textes précis sur comment ça va être
mise en oeuvre sssa glasgow c'est ça le
principal objectif de glasgow et glasgow
doit permettre d'achever ce travail là
ça veut dire quoi que nous allons partir
de paris qui était la négociation à
matin une nouvelle période où on est
maintenant entré en action on n'est plus
en train de négocier on va entrer en
action dans les prochaines coop nous
devons être pour rendre compte les
prochaines comme van aide pour élever
l'ambition à partir de 2022
c'est fini on n'est plus dans des coques
pour négocier dans des coques points
rend compte de tout ce qu'on a fait on
va rentrer dans les deux prochaines
années dans ce qu'on appelle le global
stoptech logo base globale stoptech sait
comment le monde est en train d'aller
vers de lutter contre les changements
climatiques et là on va rentrer dans des
calculs et c'est ça la prochaine ère des
changements climatiques c'est ça la
prochaine ère des négociations on est
parti des négociations pour dent pour
l'action et pour rendre compte de ce
qu'on fait comptez changement climatique
je comprends la frustration de peu du
style qui est tout à fait normal les
initiatives dont il parle sont les
initiatives africaines sur l'adaptation
et sur l'énergie significative
malheureusement n'ont pas pu voir le
jour à cause du manque de financement
aujourd'hui et nous lançant ce je
soutiens le cri d'alarmé de cette ong
qui demande que des soutiens effectifs
soit faite pour les actions qui touchent
les populations réellement
chez elle alors vous parler d'action
pour éviter ce constat sévère que l'on
vient d'en entendre par la voix de cet
expert qu'allez vous faire concrètement
est ce que vous allez taper du poing sur
la table à la cop16 imposer un ordre du
jour sans rien subir cette fois nous
avons déjà
proposé les points qui nous parviennent
qui nous paraissent importants donc
chaque partie chaque groupe a le droit
lorsqu'il ya des codes de demander que
des points importants se sont inscrits à
l'ordre du jour et c'est ce que nous
avons fait nous avons utilisé notre
droit nous attendons maintenant donc le
démarrage de la coop pouvoir si l'agenda
respecte les priorités de l'afrique
sinon effectivement la frite après du
poing sur la table pour s'exprimer pour
que sa voix soit entendue comme toutes
les autres parties comme toutes les
autres groupes donc nous ne devons pas
être mise en minorité nos points
importants sur l'adaptation sur le
financement à long terme et sur les 100
milliards de dollars donc nous allons de
nous avons demandé que ces points soit
explicitement mis à l'ordre du jour et
nous espérons que ce sera le cas et que
des discussions soient créés là dessus
et si rien ne se passe à la coop 26 à
quoi s'attendre pour les décennies à
venir écouter ce qu'on pense à agustin
yamachiche et nous sommes dans un
contexte lourd si la politique africaine
ne prend pas si les changements
climatiques c'est que au revoir toupane
vous avez cassé moment même le cameroun
s'est engagé dans l'énergie renouvelable
ce qui viennent id idéologique et
l'énergie et de l'eau j mais s'ils
avaient pas reprendre les conséquences
du changement climatique que j'aime
vestimentaires ont perdu et d'hommes
dénude chambre
limitation des places bien les gens vont
continuer a surpris et ce qui est un peu
inquiétant c'est que ce n'est pas ce
qu'ils sont riches qui en souffrent du
changement climatique nous est fait
n'est pas du changement qui m'a dit mais
c'est tout les pauvres parce que la
mobilité n'est pas seulement étaient
prédisposés a été affectée par les
effets des changements climatiques
mais la capacité de s'élever car on est
tombé à cause du
temps guillaume à vous partager la vie
de cet expert à quoi il faut s'attendre
à l'horizon 2030 et au delà si rien
n'est décidé concrètement la coop 26
alors le cas de l'afrique est
particulier parce que comme l'a répété
encore l'expert avant - nous ne sommes
pas responsables la situation le dernier
rapport du giec nous dit clairement
qu'aujourd'hui nous avons déjà depuis
1850 nous avons augmenté de 1,1 degré la
température et c'est à cause de l'homme
si nous atteignons nous le seuil est de
1 5 degré aujourd'hui toutes les haines
d'ici qui ont été publiés nous montre
qu'on va sur des seuils de plus tôt 3
degrés donc et ils préviennent si on
dépasse ce seuil de 1 5° les
catastrophes vont être exagérées et la
chaleur ressentie va en dame va va nuire
à la pluviométrie et aqua des
sécheresses il faut déjà savoir que
l'afrique est le continent le plus chaud
au monde donc ce qui veut dire que le
continent qui n'a rien fait sera celui
qui va subir le plus de vagues de
chaleur sera celui et celui qui
dépendent le plus de la nature de
l'agriculture fait à partir de la
pluviométrie donc ce continent là va
être le plus impacté en termes
d'alimentation le plus impacté en terre
de sécheresse plus impactée en termes
d'accès à l'eau alors que c'est le
continent qui n'a rien fait donc pour
nous effectivement c'est un véritable
problème c'est pour ça que lorsque nous
nous adressons nous voulons des réponses
sérieuses comment faisons nous pour nous
préparer à ce qui va arriver les 100
milliards de dollars que qui sont promis
ne sont pas des 100 milliards de là pour
assurer notre développement économique
c'est 100 milliards de dollars pour
pouvoir pallier pour pouvoir financer
les mesures de protection contre les
effets néfastes des changements
climatiques et c'est pour ça que nous
parlons souvent de cri d'alarmé parce
que les continents qui sont les plus
responsables sont souvent ceux qui
auront le moins d'effets et ça ce n'est
pas normal effectivement et tanguy yahoo
mais on va écouter maintenant des
questions qui vous sont adressés
recueillies en côte d'ivoire écoutez
selon des statistiques
l'afrique est le continent qui produit
le moins de déchets comment se fait il
en griffe que nos eaux sont les plus
pollués par tanguy yahoo mais c'est vrai
l'afrique produit moins de déchet mais
en revanche il reste beaucoup à faire en
matière de gestion des ordures et
d'assainissement des eaux également il
faut partir d'un constat l'afrique est
l'un des continents les plus
urbanisées urbanisées non pas dans le
sens où il ya beaucoup d'infractions
mais dans le sens où la majorité des
populations africaines vivent dans les
villes maintenant donc par exemple au
gabon 70% de la population vit dans la
capitale les zones rurales sont laissés
pour compte donc si 70% que dans la
capitale et que les infrastructures
sanitaires environnementales ou de lutte
aux changements climatiques ne sont pas
au point il ya une surcharge évidente et
ça c'est un des risques pour l'afrique
c'est que nous sommes hyper urbanisées
au gabon les populations du scion 1 % du
territoire tout le reste du territoire
est couvert par les activités
économiques donc forestier 1 milliards
etc mais les populations lui sur un pour
cent du territoire et donc concentrent
les déchets concentre insalubrité sur ce
pourcentage là et ce qui est très
difficile justement pour les
gouvernements les municipalités pour y
faire face deuxième question a tangué
galoubet et j'aimerais ça avoir par
rapport à la pollution ici par exemple
ici en côte d'ivoire il ya des caniveaux
qui sont tout le temps de bush et non
j'aimerais savoir ce qu'on pouvait faire
ou bien calce quels moyens qu'on
pourrait utiliser
sensibiliser la population une variante
par rapport aux autres qu'on retrouve
dans les caniveaux
temps guillaume a
alors ça ça rejoint donc la question
précédente sur l'urbanisation
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que l'afrique
ne bénéficient pas les infrastructures
nécessaires pour lutter contre ce genre
de contre son urbanisation aujourd'hui
nous devons avoir des programmes pour
nos bassins versants pour avoir des
bassins versants qui permettent
justement de contenir les déchets qui
sont mis dedans nous devons en afrique
par exemple les gens en vie il y a de
l'urbanisation anarchique donc il y a
une grosse partie de la population
puisqu'elle veut vivre en ville vont
s'installer dans des zones où on ne
devrait pas s'installer donc coupé le
cours des cours d'eau dévier des bassins
versants où vivre dans des cuvettes donc
dans des vallées et ce qui fait que ça
ça crée des problèmes aujourd'hui nous
devons avoir des programmes pour lutter
contre ça c'est pour ça que nous faisons
appel au fonds vert pour le climat mais
à chaque fois que nous faisons des
programmes par exemple d'assainissement
de l'eau au fonds vert pour le climat
ces programmes sont refusés soi disant
que ce soit des puissants des programmes
de développement économique et non pas
des programmes de lutte contre les
changements climatiques
or ces questions sont extrêmement liés
comment peut-on se développer comment
peut-on lutter conditions climatiques
sont n'a pas l'organisation nécessaire
donc ça fait partie des grosses
questions qu'on a nos programmes que
nous proposons aux financements sont
très souvent jugée des programmes
d'infrastructures donc des programmes de
développement économique et non pas de
lutte contre les changements climatiques
troisième et dernière question
pourquoi malgré tout les alertes qu'on
peut constater à travers le climat
la pollution et
la blais pénurie qu'on voit tous ces
dégâts environnementaux qu'on a pu
constater qu'ils sont liés au
réchauffement climatique ou comme malgré
tout ça on n'arrive pas à prendre des
décisions qui vont nous emmener a réagi
de manière efficace pour
on va dire freiner ce fléau la qui si on
ne le fait pas mais pas tout le monde
dans le pétrole sur l'action à des
politiques tanguy yaouba et j'ajouterais
également est ce que les délégations
africaines vont parler d'une même voix à
la coop 26 alors cette dernière question
est essentielle pour comprendre pourquoi
l'afrique se bat dans le cadre des
changements climatiques et dans le cadre
des coques les changements climatiques
demande trois choses la première c'est
de disposer des données nous permettant
de qualifier un événement un incident
une perturbation météorologique par
exemple comme étant du changement
climatique et l'afrique ne dispose pas
de suffisamment de données suffisamment
d'instruments là dessus la deuxième
chose de bénéficier
d'outils de planification
on a vu tout à l'heure des problèmes
liés à
une urbanisation anarchique aujourd'hui
l'afrique
devrait se doter tous les pays africains
devraient se doter au moins d'un plan
national d'adaptation donc pour savoir
quelle va être la planification peut se
refaire comme changement climatique
malheureusement aujourd'hui seulement
six pays africains sur les 54 pays
africains ont pu réaliser cet exercice
là et le publier donc on n'a pas de
planification en termes d'adaptation
donc on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui va
nous arriver et on ne sait pas quelles
sont les mesures qu'il faut prendre pour
ça parce que l'appui que nous avons est
insuffisant et nous économie étant les
économies qui tendent à devenir
émergentes il y à peu d'argent que nous
pouvons investir vers ces études là qui
ne sont pas de notre responsabilité les
gouvernements mettre l'accent sur des
projets de développement des projets
sociaux ou des projets de santé est très
peu d'argent effectivement pour
l'instant dans les projets compte les
changements climatiques qui sont du
ressort de la communauté internationale
donc oui l'afrique va parler d'une même
voix parce que nous nos problèmes sont
les mêmes nous sommes réunis en ce
moment à glasgow pour préparer justement
notre position depuis deux jours déjà
nous avons tenu des réunions intense et
nous sommes prêts pour démarrer la
semaine prochaine avec encore quatre
cinq jours de réunions cette semaine
pour pouvoir parler d'une seule et même
boîte durant celle coop qui vaille c'est
vrai une partie technique mais
extrêmement politique avec toute une
semaine qui sera au niveau ministériel
et pour lesquels les grandes questions
vont être réglé à ce niveau là et où
l'afrique parlera d'une seule et même
voix merci beaucoup à vous tanguy yaouba
et bonne chance à glasgow a retrouvé à
free connecte sur nos réseaux sociaux et
en replay sur rt france point tv merci à
toutes les équipes du mag et techniques
pour la préparation de cette émission
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt dans un trait connecte sur arte
france